hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight we
have a lot to get to and first Red Wave
Rising that is the focus of tonight's
angle
[Music]
oh have you checked this out the bad
news keeps rolling in for Biden and the
Democrats it's so sad a New York Times
poll has Trump edging Biden 45 to 44
among likely voters and that's the key
metric now remember this is even with
Biden's horror show economy a one-point
lead for the former president is
stunning now think of the near non-stop
negative coverage Trump's given by the
regime media so I'm thinking to myself
today imagine what this poll might look
like if the Press were even a smidge
Fair
and other New York Times polling data
spells Doom for the Democrats as well in
the generic ballot Republicans now hold
a four-point lead over Democrats that's
a five-point swing toward the GOP since
September it's devastating and perhaps
most significant there's a lot of
significant stuff in this poll the
biggest shift came from women who
identified as independent voters in
September they favor Democrats by 14
points now Independent Women backed
Republicans by 18 points I thought that
was a typo but it's not and on top of
that almost two-thirds of Americans
believe we're going in the wrong
direction 64 percent
now at this point I think it's good to
remember where things look back in June
and July that was after the court
overturned Roe and liberals were really
hopeful even predicting that the voters
would turn away from the GOP when
abortion rights are on the ballot
Republicans are the party of extreme
well Democrats meantime hope the fight
over abortion will take Center State
during mid-term elections later this
year Republicans continue to lose ground
and white-collar suburbs and abortion is
a big part of that it's helping
Democrats I think Dobb's decision is
going to do more to get people out to
vote
really clear that's why you're a former
now we didn't fall for any of that
voters have signaled that their number
one concern is the economy and oh wait
where does abortion fall according to
Pew it's the eighth most important
priority behind things like education
safety and Supreme Court appointments
and yes the angle was correct today
they're these are where the issues rank
among likely voters the economy and
inflation combined add up to about 44
percent abortion it's now down to five
percent it was eight percent before
and despite the millions of dollars
poured into campaign ads Coast to Coast
this is accusing Republicans of course
of turning back the clock on women's
health care only eight percent of likely
Democratic voters said abortion was
their top concern eight percent
and with economic concerns weighing most
heavily on the minds of Voters you have
to ask which party do the voters think
is better equipped at the money thing
well Republicans buy a big margin now
with the numbers looking this Grim for
the party of Biden Pelosi and AOC all of
them combined what can they do at this
point to turn things around
well they look for a rescue operation
for the guy they still consider they're
only real president and they hope he can
help change the subject
they increasingly
um are willing to subvert basic
Democratic procedures right like let's
count votes let's make sure that people
are allowed to vote let's make sure that
uh whoever gets the most votes has the
most seats and that if they get the most
votes in Congress that you can pass laws
right
basic stuff like that they don't
increasingly seem to believe in and it's
a reminder that democracy is fragile you
have to fight for it and this midterm
election I think is going to be a moment
in which
um you know that battle has to be joined
oh wait is he over oh my gosh he sounds
like he was boring himself in that
recitation but here's the problem for Mr
Martha's Vineyard hope and change is now
hopeless and pocket change
and speaking of desperate that brings us
to
[Music]
when you think about the inflation
reduction act and what Republicans want
to do is
to repeal that very historic piece of
legislation that is also going to lower
energy costs Republicans are actually
going to make things worse and Democrats
want to do the opposite and make things
a little easier
I think she's I think she's gotten
better at reading frankly joining me now
is Stephen Miller former senior advisor
to president Trump founder of America
First legal Stephen bringing out Obama
uh the lies from kjp is any of that
going to work given where these numbers
are that was shocking 18 of of likely
Independent Women now swinging uh the
other way to Republicans that New York
Times Sienna poll is just a hammer blow
to Democrat hopes in three weeks from
now and the movement of Women Voters in
particular as you pointed out I've never
seen that much movement in so short a
Time 18 plus for the for the GOP among
complete reversal of Fortune what that
tells me is that Republican messaging on
Three core issues crime immigration and
inflation is bringing Women Voters into
the GOP tent which spells a death nail
for the Democratic party in three weeks
from now
well Obama back to him being back to the
rescue I think he was trying to have
kind of a a sister Soldier light moment
let's watch this
not being a buzz kill right yeah that's
a lesson for the Democratic yeah and
sometimes Democrats are right it's it's
like you know sometimes people just want
to not feel as if
they are
walking on eggshells uh and and and they
want to acknowledgment that life is
messy and that all of us
at any given moment can
you know say things the wrong way you
know make mistakes
talking about cancel culture there is a
little rusty don't you sound a little
Meandering and a very oblique reference
to cancer culture what does that get him
he's clearly out of practice but I think
what he's actually trying to do is he
knows that Biden is in for a shellacking
in just 22 days from now and so I think
he's actually trying to establish some
distance between himself and the current
Democratic party brand and to your to
your core question is any of this going
to work trotting out Obama trotting out
kjp trying desperately to change the
subject to anything at all it won't work
because to use a common expression they
have a reality problem the border is
open Crime is out of control inflation
is at a 40-year high as long as
Republicans stay relentlessly on those
points they will win and kjp was also
asked about why candidates aren't wild
about the prospect of campaigning with
Joe Biden
the president has been traveling
Non-Stop and he's going to continue to
be on the road non-stop he's going to go
where he is needed the most and at this
time uh we're not we don't have just any
additional we just don't have any
additional travel to to lay out for you
oh that was real reading time with kjp I
mean it's embarrassing at this point I
mean they just can't he's a Kryptonite
he can't well first of all you think by
nowadays a theater term she'd be off
book it's astonishing that months now
into the job she can answer a simple
question without looking down whenever
an intern prepared for her and the fact
that they don't have an answer to that
question which they would know is coming
just shows that this was a white house
in complete disarray I I'd never think I
would say this but I miss I miss Jen
saki all right Stephen great to see you
tonight as always hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else